so earlier this year I tweeted us saying
that interest rates 30 or fix could
crack 10 I talked about on the podcast I
made videos about it people said you're
out of your mind this will never happen
you're crazy cannot believe you're
saying this you spin out all this fear
porn I said look guys this is what I
think is going to happen we're in a
weird economy I think we're going to
crack 10 when I said that a Dave Ramsey
came out and posted this on his
Instagram post to calm everybody down
here's what Dave Ramsey said so here's
what he said on Instagram he posted
something about it on June 29th now keep
in mind the rates at that time were
roughly five percent he said the
following the housing market is not
crashing inflation recession High
interest rates High fuel costs labor
market disruption including the great
resignation supply chain shortages bear
market and the hits keep coming are we
heading for the end of the American
economy is the housing market going to
crash is this generation going to be
priced out of the housing market and
never be homeowners again he says no no
no the only one I want to talk about out
is the second one is the housing market
going to crash he said no he says sorry
to end your fear porn party but the
sky's really not falling it's definitely
scary and some of the things going on
truly do suck but the sky is not falling
now keep in mind I'm sure when the
average realtor or loan officer reads
this they're like oh my God that's
awesome Dave Ramsey are on our side it's
fantastic thank you for posting
something like this you know we need
your support but here's the reality of
it I don't want your support
what the truth is what I want because
when this was posted June 29th rates
were roughly five percent you know what
the 30-year fixes today roughly seven
and a half percent it's gone up 50
percent on the five percent two and a
half percent has gone up since five
percent and it's only got another two
and a half to go to crack ten percent
now people will say again Pat are you
out of your mind let's do a little
homework together here's how interest
rates have been since 1970 and by the
way do you know what's the lowest
30-year fix has ever cracked 2.65 when
do you think that was last year okay you
think that's gonna last forever people
were buying left and right thinking it's
going to be oh my home value it's a
three million dollar home no it's not
it's probably 1.7 we sold it for 3
million because rates were at 2.65 it is
not a three million dollar home at seven
and a half percent interest rates it's
just not everybody today is selling
their luxuries their exotic cars their
planes their boats just yesterday they
got another yacht package coming up with
new ones on discount yesterday I'm at
the airport looking at private jets do
you know what numbers they're
discounting it at 50 percent Global
Express 5000 you know G5 all these guys
discount discount discount why because
some of these guys bought one too many
private all the vacations home in Aspen
right now all these vacations some
people have a second one third one
fourth one watch this here's the rates
the last 50 years let's take a look at
this together all right so take a look
on 2021 it shows 2.96 right the average
third year for the year 2.96 the year
before 3-1 2019 394 454. you'll see a
bunch of threes and fours and we'll see
five in 2009 then you see sixes and
eight seven six then you'll see fives
again then you see sixes 1994 8.38 then
you see a bunch of eights and nines then
1990 what do you see there
10.13 just 32 years ago people have such
a short-term memory this was only 32
years ago then you go 1989 10-3 tell me
one year between 74 and 1989 where the
rates were lower more than 8.85 percent
you don't see one year by the way look
at 1980 look in 1979 81 82 83 84 85 86
87 88 89 every one of those years the
average 30-year fix was over 10 percent
11.2 1979 13.74 1663 16 13 24 1388 12 10
10 10. what does this mean when we do
our homework when we actually do a
little bit of due diligence and stop
falling for this motivational post to
make everybody feel good everything's
gonna be okay when I'm in the military
we're at War I don't want my sergeant to
come up to me and tell me hey guys guess
what it's going to be fun we're going to
win this war yeah they may attack us
from all these other places but we're
going to be totally fine no I want my
sergeant my captain my Colonel my SAR
major to be paranoid I want them to say
if they attack us from here we got to do
this this could happen guys you could
get killed you better stay learned stay
alive that's the mindset this is why in
the world of business outside of
motivational speakers in the real world
of business only the paranoid survive
was a statement and a book written by
one of the greatest CEO of the past
generation Andy Grove who everybody in
Silicon Valley duplicated so rates 10
maybe right now I say man the way patch
is broken down 10 around the corner what
happens if rates go to ten percent what
happens to 2 million dollar value of a
property being sold last year at 2.65 at
two points at two million dollars what
do you think that two million dollar
home is going to be worth when the rate
said ten percent 1.5 1 million oh
there's no way it's going to drop 25
percent there's no way it's going to
drop 50 okay we'll see maybe I want to
be wrong I'm very comfortable with not
being wrong with being wrong but
when you print as much money as
America's printed that we did the last
couple years and we put fake success
into the economy people actually think
they're better than they really are
people actually get fooled into thinking
they're smarter than they really are
they're brilliant Brokers they're
brilliant this and anytime you become a
little too cocky you lose yesterday
Dylan had a 150 point lead on me on uh
uh The Dominoes while we're playing and
he's talking trash to me I said Dylan be
very careful being cocky because you're
playing against somebody that knows what
they're doing and dominoes you know how
the night ended daddy whooped his butt
and enjoyed it I'm trying to persuade
this kid to believe don't get cocky your
daddy knows how to be cocky I lost a lot
in my 20s being cocky I learned only the
paranoids survive so watch what Yahoo
finance says today in an article let's
take a look at what's going on in Las
Vegas because Las Vegas is the leading
indicator of what happens to real estate
you ready for this let's read this
together Las Vegas is one of the leading
indicators for home price action in the
housing market like we saw in 2008 and
the recent Frenzy we are absolutely
feeling the heat here the buyer pool has
for the most part dried up says Crystal
rifle a real estate agent in Las Vegas
tells Fortune now look at the next one
here at the bottom in fact as of last
week mortgage purchase applications are
down you ready 38 a year-over-year basis
that marks the lowest reading since
2014. next page look at this one here
Realtors are feeling the big time as
well I put in a call to greater greater
Las Vegas Association of Realtors and
the employee I spoke with said that they
are they were averaging about 300 new
members every month new Realtors meaning
this one she has estimated 120 however
she has been processing you ready for
this about 30 Realtors withdrawals a day
rifle says that means every day around
30 real estate agents in Las Vegas alone
are calling it quiz I wonder why and by
the way this is just Las Vegas this is
not all across the country these are
some people that were making 230 400 000
of your income that are sitting there
saying everything's dried up people are
not buying new homes mortgage is not
going there so now here's a couple
things that could happen all those
people that were saying this is just
fear porn you're like Dave Ramsey don't
worry about it it's going to be all
right of course long term everything's
gonna be all right of course and long
term we're going to be fine this isn't a
long-term conversation the market does
fine long term Dow's been up long term
housing value has been up long term all
that stuff's been fine long term but in
the current times this could last a year
to two years maybe two and a half years
Elon Musk said since until spring of
2024 is what he thinks recession is
going to last through who does that hurt
the people that were not ready for this
season and they heard the wrong opinion
because it's selective hearing just
please tell me stuff I want to hear I
don't want to listen to what Pat's got
to say because that's fear point just
please tell me what I want to hear and
we avoid wanting to hear reality
and this game can be an ugly game when
all you want to hear is good news so
having said that for some of you guys
that are still sticking around I don't
know if it's going to hit 10 I'm
convinced it will I'm convinced it could
go higher than 10 and I'm convinced the
next two years going to be very ugly I'm
convinced everything's going to be on
sale in 2023. I'm convinced after
midterms things are going to be very
strange I'm also convinced the day after
2024 election Dow's gonna have its
biggest single day ever I'm convinced
SMP is going to have its biggest Day
Ever After 2024 November elections I'm
convinced of that but that's two years
from today so if you're watching this
and you say I still disagree with you
totally fine I made a video
two months ago three months ago talking
about why I believe the real estate
market bubble is really taking place if
you've not seen it you may want to see
it and you can ask me any questions you
want on Twitter and say Pat I disagree
with you in the following things and we
can have a conversation you can tweet me
at Patrick David I'll respond if it's a
respectful comment I'll respond to you
but I suggest you watch this video a
little bit deeper if you want to find
out what's really going on behind closed
doors when you look at the real estate
market what indicators you and I should
be paying attention to having said that
future still looks bright long term but
it's going to be a little bit Rocky
short term the next 12 to 24 months
foreign